الكلمه الان لرئيس مجلس الوزراء الكويتيه
الشيخ احمد نواف الاحمد الصباح صاحب
الجلاله الملك عبد الله بن الحسين
ملك المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه الشقيقه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اصحاب
المعالي والسعاده
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
ان اتقدم بجزيل الشكر والتقدير لجلاله
الملك عبد الله بن الحسين
والى حكومه والشعب المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه الشقيقه
على حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرم الضيافه والاعداد المتميز لهذا
اللقاء المهم
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
ياتي لقائنا اليوم
في اشاره واضحه ودلاله قاطعه
على اهتمام المجتمع الدولي بامن واستقرار
العراق
والقناه الراسخه بان المنطقه لن تنعد لن
تنعم بالاستقرار
ولن تنهى بالامن ان فقدت احدى دول
واجراك دول الجوار لهذه لهذه الحقيقه
وسعيهم لصيانه امنهم واستقرار المنطقه
ولا يفوتني هنا ان اهنئ الاشقاء بما تحقق
لهم من اتمام الانتخابات التشريعيه
واختيار رئيس الوزراء
وحصول الحكومه على موافقه البرلمان اضافه
الى ما تحقق ايضا للاشقاء في صيانه امنهم
و دعم استقرارهم في طريق القضاء على ما
تبقى من فلول المنظمات الارهابيه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
تدرك الدول العربيه ولا سيما دول مجلس
التعاون لدول الخليج العربيه
مكانه العراق
واهميته في المحيط الاقليمي والدولي
وتسعى لاستعاده دوره الفاعل
في تعزيز تواجده في محيطه العربي
ليمارس دوره المعهود بحريه
بعيدا عن اي تاثيرات خارجيه
وما اتفاقيه الربط الكهربائي الموقعه بين
دول مجلس التعاون وجمهوريه العراق
الا مثال على ذلك السعي اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسمو
سعد دوله الكويت لدعم جمهوريه العراق في
كافه المجالات
ادراك منها لاهميه هذا البلد الشقيق
وترسيقا للقناعه السائده
بان امن البلدين والمنطقه واستقرارهما كل
لا يتجزا
وتجسيدا لعمق العلاقات الاخويه التي
تجمعنا
فجاء الدعم
الكويتي
اقتصاديا وتنمويه عبر مؤتمر الكويت الدولي
لاعاده اعمار العراق فبراير 20 18
او عبر المشاريع الاخرى التي قامت بها
دوله الكويت
وامنيا عبر مشاركتها الفعاله ضمن التحالف
الدولي ضد داعش
وغيرها من اوجه الدعم التي قدمتها دوله
الكويت عبر السنوات
ولا يفوتني ان استذكر بالتقدير الزياره
التي قام بها اخي دوله رئيس الوزراء محمد
شياع السوداني الى دوله الكويت مؤخرا
والتي حرص على ان تكون من اوائل زياراته
الخارجيه في دلاله واضحه لا تحتاج الى
بيان
ان انا مطالبون اليوم امام حجم ما يربطنا
من علاقات الى العمل على اغلاق كافه
الملفات العالقه
ولا سينما استكمال ترسيم الحدود البحريه
بعد العلامه
وذلك لننطلق معا في الانتقال بعلاقاتنا
الى افاق جديده تعكس ما يربطنا ورقبه
ورقبه قيادي
بلدينا وتطلعات شعبان الشقيقين
نفوت الفرصه على من داب على استقلال هذه
الملفات في بث بث اكاذيب وتلفيقات
للنيل من هذه العلاقه وتعكير صفها
فالاراده متوفره والحرص على سياده كل بلد
منا لا سبيل للنقاش به
والاليات والقوانين الدوليه كقواعد يمكن
الركوني لها دامقه وحاسمه فلا مجال
للتاخير والتاجيل لتحقيق مصالحنا المشتركه
ونتفرق معا لتعزيز علاقاتنا
ولمواجهه التحديات الجسيمه على المستويين
الاقليمي والدولي
مجدد الشكر لكم جميعا
متمنيا للاشقاء في العراق تحقيق المزيد من
امالهم وتطلعاتهم
ولمؤتمرنا التوفيق والسداد والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته